let me ask uh you kind of uh
took a step back to the genome outside
of just humans but is there something
that you find beautiful about the human
genome specifically
so i think the genome if more people
understood
the beauty of the human genome there
would be so many fewer wars
so much less anger in the world i mean
what's really beautiful about the human
genome is really
the variation that teaches us both about
individuality
and about similarity so any two people
on the planet
are 99.9 identical
how can you fight with someone who's
99.9
identical to you it's just
counterintuitive
and yet any two siblings of the same
parent
differ in millions of locations
so every one of them is basically two to
the million
unique from any pair of parents let
alone any two random parents on the
planet
so that's i think something that teaches
us about sort of the nature of humanity
in many ways
that every one of us is as unique as any
star
and way more unique in actually many
ways and
uh yet we're all brothers and sisters
and yeah just like stars most of it is
just uh
fusion uh reactions yeah you only have a
few parameters to describe stars
yeah you know mass size initial size and
you know stage of life whereas for
humans it's you know
thousands of parameters scattered across
our genome
so the other thing that makes humans
unique
the other things that makes inheritance
unique in humans
is that uh most species
inherit things vertically basically
instinct
is a huge part of their behavior the way
that
you know i mean with my kids we've been
watching this uh
nest of birds uh with two little eggs
you know outside our window for the last
few months uh for the last few weeks as
they've been growing
and there's so much behavior
that's hard-coded birds don't just learn
as they grow they don't you know there's
no culture
like a bird that's born in boston will
be the same as a bird that's born in
california
so there's not as much
inheritance of ideas of customs
a lot of it is hard-coded in their
genome what's really beautiful about the
human genome is that
if you take a person from today and you
place them back in ancient egypt
or if you take a person from ancient
egypt and you place them here today
they will grow up to be completely
normal
that is not genetics this is
the other type of inheritance in humans
so on one hand we have genetic
inheritance which is vertical
from your parents down on the other hand
we have horizontal inheritance which is
the ideas that are built up at every
generation
are horizontally transmitted and the
huge
amount of time that we spend in
educating ourselves
a concept known as niotini neo for
newborn and then tenny for
holding so if you look at humans i mean
the little birds there were you know
eggs two weeks ago and that
now one of them has already flown off
the other one's ready to fly off
in two weeks they're ready to just fend
for themselves humans
16 years 18 years 24 getting out of
college i'm still learning
so so that's so fascinating the this
picture of a vertical in the horizontal
i when you talk about the horizontal is
it in the realm of ideas
exactly okay so it's the actual social
interactions and that's exactly right
that's exactly right so basically the
concept of neoteny
is that you spend acquiring
characteristics from your environment
in an extremely malleable state of your
brain and the wiring of your brain
for a long period of your life compared
to primates
we are useless you take any primate at
seven weeks and
in a human at seven weeks we lose the
battle but at 18 years
you know all bets are off like we
basically our brain continues to develop
in an extremely malleable form until
very late
and this is what allows education this
is what allows
the person from egypt to do extremely
well now
and the reason for that is that
the wiring of our brain
and the development of that wiring is
actually delayed
so you know the longer you delay that
the more opportunity you have
to pass on knowledge to pass on concepts
ideals
ideas from the parents to the child
and what's really absolutely beautiful
about humans today is that that lateral
transfer of ideas and culture
is not just from uncles and aunts and
teachers at school
but it's from wikipedia and review
articles on the web
and thousands of journals that are sort
of putting out
information for free and podcasts and
videocasts and all of that stuff
where you can basically learn about any
topic
pretty much everything that would be in
any
super advanced textbook in a matter of
days
instead of having to go to the library
of alexandria
and sail there to read three books and
then sail for another few days to get to
athens and
et cetera et cetera so the
democratization of knowledge
and the spread the speed of spread of
knowledge is what
defines i think the human inheritance
pattern
you